[ROARING]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
[CHEERING]
[PEPPY MUSIC]
What's up, everyone?
This is "Disney+ Deets," where
we break down everything
you need to know
about your favorite
Disney+ movies and series.
I'm Kenneth.
And I'm Marcellus, and,
not to do our own horns,
but we're pretty much the
biggest Disney+ fans out there.
No, let's do it.
Toot, toot.
Beep, beep.
That's right.
Let's get into it.
KENNETH: I'm assembling a team.
MARCELLUS: Who are
you, Nick Fury?
KENNETH: Maybe.
I left my eye patch at home.
MARCELLUS: It's time to talk
about Marvel Studios' "The
Avengers," an epic adventure
full of incredible heroics,
terrifying villainy, and
mind-blowing special effects.
KENNETH: It all started with
the Marvel comic created by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby in 1963.
They assembled a team of Earth's
mightiest heroes: the Avengers.
MARCELLUS: In 2012,
that comic book team
came to life on the big screen.
This epic installment into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
completed Phase 1 of
the Infinity Saga.
It all began in 2008 with the
unforgettable post-credit scene
in Marvel Studios' "Iron Man."
You mean the introduction to
one of my favorite characters,
Nick Fury.
MARCELLUS: You've become a
part of a bigger universe.
You just don't know it yet.
KENNETH: That's the one.
MARCELLUS: According to Kevin
Feige, chief creative officer
of Marvel Studios, the
idea for "The Avengers"
actually grew out of
this memorable cameo.
KENNETH: The easy move would
have been to give the fans
an Avengers movie right away.
Instead, Marvel Studios decided
to build out the universe
one superhero at a time.
They wanted to
give each character
a chance to shine before
bringing them all together.
MARCELLUS: The team is made
up of Robert Downey Jr. as Iron
Man, Chris Evans as Captain
America, Mark Ruffalo
as the Hulk, Chris
Hemsworth is Thor,
Scarlett Johansson
as Black Widow,
and Jeremy Renner as Hawkeye.
KENNETH: And of course,
Samuel L. Jackson returns
as S.H.I.E.L.D. director,
Nick Fury.
MARCELLUS: The cast of
heroes for "The Avengers"
was set from the beginning,
but the filmmakers debated
who the villain should be.
In the end, they
decided on Loki,
partly in tribute
to the very first
issue of The Avengers comic.
KENNETH: Like you always
say, Marcellus, every movie
is only as good
as their villain.
Loki, turn off the
Tesseract or I'll destroy it.
You can't.
KENNETH: I love Loki,
and Tom Hiddleston
did such an amazing job bringing
the God of Mischief to life.
MARCELLUS: The actors all went
through extensive training
with fight choreographer,
Jonathan Eusebio.
He taught the cast everything,
from medieval fighting
techniques to Wushu
to kung fu and Kali.
KENNETH: Black Widow is amazing!
And I love how she
just effortlessly
is like, OK, let me take
care of this real quick.
MARCELLUS: [LAUGHS] Right.
Just like Budapest
all over again.
You and I remember
Budapest very differently.
KENNETH: To play
Hawkeye, Jeremy Renner
trained with Olympic archers.
One of the hardest
tasks to master
was drawing back his
heavy bow with both speed
and consistency.
Hawkeye is the
ultimate master archer,
so he definitely can't
be slow on the draw.
MARCELLUS: The rest of the
cast was training hard too.
Hiddleston and Hemsworth both
did a lot of their own stunts
to bring a level of
authenticity to the screen.
Hiddleston knew that the
more you saw an actor's face,
the more you would be
invested in the characters.
KENNETH: I liked the
fact that I was getting
ready to see all of
my favorite characters
using their superpowers.
MARCELLUS: Absolutely.
KENNETH: You had Iron
Man using his suit.
You had Black Widow
kicking and jumping.
We had Hawkeye with his bows.
You had Captain America with his
shield made out of vibranium.
I was here for it!
Hulk was smashing!
Thor was throwing
lightning in his hammer!
Everywhere I looked
there was action!
I was on the edge
of my seat, sir!
MARCELLUS: It was glorious.
The Hulk got some extra love
from the special effects
department.
The goal was to create a
version of the character that
had never been seen before.
In previous movies, the
Hulk was entirely CGI.
For this movie, a
new motion capture
technology allowed Ruffalo to
play both Banner and the Hulk.
KENNETH: So when Banner
finally hulks out,
you realize, whoa, that's
still Ruffalo's face!
All his expressions have
been captured and transferred
onto the big, angry, green dude.
I was here for the Hulk!
Hulk, smash!
MARCELLUS: The iconic New York
City moments were actually
filmed in downtown Cleveland.
False building facades were
created to transform the city,
and they even built a
fake New York subway stop.
KENNETH: Don't worry.
There's plenty of real
New York in the movie
too, like the scene shot
at the Bethesda Fountain
in Central Park.
MARCELLUS: It takes a lot to
get New Yorkers' attention,
but Thor walking around Central
Park in his Asgardian cape
did the trick.
Huge crowds of paparazzi
and fans showed up.
That's how they respond to me
when I'm in my Asgardian cape.
MARCELLUS: For Feige, it
was important for the story
to stand on its own.
He wanted the audience
to enjoy "The Avengers"
even if they'd never seen
another Marvel movie.
KENNETH: It's the colorful
personalities of the heroes,
all banding together
that everyone loves.
Feige says, it's those
character-driven moments
that really stick
with audiences,
even more than the big,
spectacular battles.
I just love how this
movie gives hope.
No matter what's going
on, you know the Avengers
are coming to save the day.
It just makes you feel good.
There was excitement seeing
all of my favorite comic book
characters on screen.
You know what, Ken?
For me, this movie really showed
me that it's all about teamwork
and coming together.
Sometimes you disagree,
but if you come together,
you're stronger than what you
were if you were separated.
KENNETH: And that's
our show for today.
Be sure to like,
subscribe, and check
out Marvel Studios'
"The Avengers,"
now streaming on Disney+.
Take care of yourselves
and the planet,
and we'll see you next time.
Marcellus and Ken signing off.
KENNETH: Marcellus, let's
go join the Avengers.
MARCELLUS: Ooh, I need
to work out first.
KENNETH: [LAUGHS] OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]